nous retournons maintenant à la cour
neuve il y a 1 an le 19 juin 2005 un
enfant a été tué par une balle perdue
lors d'un règlement de compte l'affaire
avait provoqué une vive émotion des
promesses avaient été faites par Nicolas
Sarkozi promesse d'emploi pour les
jeunes du quartier promesse de renfort
d'effectif au commissariat 12 mois plus
tard le maire de La Courneuve estime que
ses engagements n'ont pas été tenus
alors qu'en est-il réellement enquête
Gilles Marinet Tristan Lebas le terme
nettoyé au carchè un terme qui s'impose
c'était en juin 2005 après la mort du
petit Sidi Amed tué par balle à la cour
neuve Nicolas Sarkozi promettait à sa
manière de restaurer la sécurité à côté
du maire communiste il annonçait
également des emplois pour les jeunes
257 embauches directes ont été
recueilli dont 158 à pourvoir
immédiatement un an plus tard le maire
affirme que rien n'a changé en matière
de sécurité les faits de délinquence
sont même augmenté de 18,43 % chiffre
officiel il attend encore les renforts
en terme de police de proximité qui est
à mon avis un des maillons essentiels
pour reprendre confiance renoué compris
le dialogue entre police et habitants
dans les quartiers on a eu aucun moyen
dédié spécifique le ministère de
l'Intérieur affirme que 10 policiers
supplémentaires ont été affectés au
commissariat de La Courneuve le maire
n'a pas obtenu la police de proximité
dont il rêve et lui faut écouter les
habitants des quartiers se plaindre des
opérations coup Depo jugé inefficace
trentaine de policiers ou de CRS pour
prendre qui un ou deux
jeunes et le soir même donc il a plein
de on peut même pas on peut même pas
sortir pour l'emploi la NPE la mission
intercommunale de grandes entreprises se
sont mobilisé 242 courneviens sont
entrés en entreprise la plupart avec des
contrats courts 42 ont décroché un CDI
164 une formation un bilan mitigé
puisque les contrats courts ont rarement
été renouvelés aujourd'hui les
entreprises ne désirent pas en parler le
profil des candidats ne coïncidait pas
toujours avec les besoins des
employeurs il y a eu beaucoup plus
d'écoute de la part des entreprises en
direction de la Mission Locale pour
l'Emploi maintenant elles ne peuvent
proposer que ce qu'elles ont en magasin
entre guillemets c'estàd les postes
qu'elles ont l'intention de pourvoir
avec des compétences attendues une
question de formation mais au pied de
certains immeubles comme à la Cité
Verlin il y a aussi ceux qui ont décidé
que les emplois proposés souvent peu
qualifiés ne leur convenait pas moi
inscrit à la NPE il y en a plein qui
sont inscrits ici à la NPE d'accord du
boulot c'est il y en a tu vois c'est pas
vrai on va pas dire qu'il y en a pas
mais les boulots qu'on nous propose
c'est des boulots de magasinier payer
906 € par mois on peut même pas préparer
notre avenir on peut rien faire du tout
avec tout ça cet état d'esprit n'est pas
celui de tous 500 jeunes avaient postulé
quelques dizaines ont trouvé un emploi
stable le taux de chômage à la cour
neuve reste de 20 %